all right this holiday season we're
watching an emerging shopping trend the
growing acceptance of previously owned
gifts the National Retail Federation
says total holiday retail sales could
top seven hundred and thirty billion
dollars but a growing number of shoppers
are looking for second hand items and
major brands are taking notice Janet
shamlian shows us a unique business near
San Francisco being called an online
treasure hunt
good morning some may raise an eyebrow
but second-hand gifting has come into
its own this holiday season and this
warehouse in the San Francisco area is
proof that brands like REI and Patagonia
are taking notice some 50-thousand like
new or slightly used items up for
secondary sale and holiday demand is
unprecedented
overflowing with everything from ski
boots to winter coats and every sporting
good imaginable Yertle is a bargain
lovers dream but you can't shop here
even though many of these customer
returns are as good as new
usually there's scuffs and scratches
yeah seeing a big market opportunity
brands like REI and Patagonia have
gotten into the game of reselling their
own used products on websites like REI
used and Patagonia's worn wear but
Yertle does all the work what's the
discount on something like that
she's probably 50% of what somebody
would have paid had they found it just
like this in the store Andy Rubin
created Yertle when he saw the secondary
clothing market growing more than 20
times faster than the primary one these
are beautiful items they're made to be
worn they should be this should be out
on the town not sitting in a closet
right everything here is refreshed then
photographed the goal is to make sure
like the colors are accurate this
women's fleece pullover was styled for
Patagonia's worn wear sight hours after
it came in it might end up under the
tree that's because a new study finds
second-hand gifting gaining broad
acceptance
48% saying they'd consider giving a used
item even more 56% say they'd welcome
one these stigmas from you know from
years ago we're changing and they're
changing quickly I think once anyone
experiences this you realize that
there's just a smarter way to utilize
the things we've already made right to
get more use out of these things the
shift in behavior led by millenials
citing affordability concerns about the
environment and sustainability do you
see this
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my goodness
Jamie sy is a social-media influencer
known as hello Jam who post videos on
thrifting at places like goodwill how
would you feel about getting a
secondhand gift send them all to me
absolutely I don't I rarely ever buy
fast fashion items because of the fact
that it's so terrible for the
environment and it's way more unique to
have secondhand items the struggling
retail industry is getting that message
made well in some of its stores has
partnered with thredUP to sell used
jeans for $50 a pair right next to its
new denim fast fashion is really a
broken system I think it's a way to be
much more creative I think it's a way to
get great value secondhand doesn't
necessarily mean inexpensive the real
real a luxury reseller has pre-owned
handbags topping $40,000 we just saw a
Chanel bag the small one over there
which is very nice my mom really liked
it so well see we might get it no longer
unthinkable I used gift comes with
something a new item can never offer a
bit of history everything we have has a
story and so you can think about all the
possible stories that that item has and
the stories that it will have when you
give it to somebody else
almost 20% of what's in here is actually
sold the same day it's listed and the
dramatic increase in sales over the past
couple of weeks
tells them these are holiday purchases
destined for under the tree Jenna got
some deals would you accept a
second-hand gift it depends on what it
was okay well in bath it depends on what
it was it depends on what it was how to
personal I love that it's good for a
wallet it's good for the environment I
do think the idea of it is very good I
like all the creative ways all the
creative ways we avoid saying used the
second-hand initially owned like new
like it was call it used I like like no
but the way they're doing it though guys
it looks really good something like that
I think it's in a different coat I think
that's great